hi my name is lucian gislin i am
senior staff engineer at beckman culture
life sciences formerly
lab site in san jose california
i'm going to speak today about acoustic
ejection mass spectrometry for high
throughput
analysis aems is a
novel integration of acoustic droplet
ejection
the open port sampling interface and
conventional electrospray ionization
mass spectrometry
we see this as a transformative system
for high throughput sampling
and label-free analysis here's the
agenda we'll begin
with a mass spectrometry overview
looking at the process of
electrosprayingization
and looking at ionization from complex
sample matrices
we're going to overview the most widely
used mass spectrometry technologies
including triple quadruple quadruple
time of flight and orbit trap
next we're on to a brief history of
separation including liquid
chromatography
and solid phase extraction we're going
to address
the separation bottleneck optical
readout
with fluorescent labels offers high
throughput
but adds complexity and is constrained
by artifacts
mass spectrometer on the other hand
offers fast sensitive
specific label-free readout however
front-end separation is hard to do there
is an
inherent throughput mismatch between
front end
and back end mass spec readout we're
going to go through microphonic sampling
including a mini sprayer ion source that
dates back 20 years
the capillary gap sampler and of course
the open port interface
we'll review an opi timeline from proof
of concept
to present day and then we're on to
applications
of acoustic ejection mass spectrometry
and bioassays real-time kinetics
high throughput screening high through
experimentation an example
to highlight the elimination of
fluorescent probe artifacts
and then we're on to in well liquid
liquid extraction this is a recent
development
for us in this technology
this is the process of electrospray
ionization we have a stainless steel
capillary the fluid sample is flowing
within the capillary there's a high
voltage applied
the high voltage generates a taylor cone
at the tip of the taylor cone
an electrospray of droplets forms those
droplets are exposed
to a heated desolvation flow of gas
as a result there is evaporation
preparation shrinks the droplets
eventually
the surface charge overcomes
surface tension and there is a droplet
efficient event you can see that in the
top right
this cycle repeats evaporation efficient
evaporation
fission it takes the droplets from 25
microns
down to the molecular scale five
nanometers
and that yields the charge analyte there
are multiple models proposed
for this ionization process as shown in
the lower
left there's ion ejection model charge
residue
model chain ejection model and collision
induced association the ion ejection
model is the most commonly discussed
and that involves the analyte near the
drop surface a transfer of charge
from the droplet surface to the analyte
and then ejection of the analyte
in the charged residue model the analyte
resides in the bulk of the droplet
as evaporation occurs charges
transferred from the droplet surface
to the analyte in the chain ejection
model one
end of the analyte chain interacts with
the droplet surface
there's a charged equilibration process
charges added to the chain eventually
the chain
is ejected from the droplet collision
induced
dissociation occurs also within the mass
spectrometer in the collision
cell here we have a precursor protein
with multiple segments
exposed to collisions and already
charged as a result of the collisions
one of the subunits
extends and is unfolded charges transfer
to this unfolded
chain and then the chain is checked in
the lower right we have a molecular
dynamics
simulation of a charged nano droplet
this drop droplet comprises
750 water and 750
methanol molecules circled in blue you
can see the analyte ion it's an ammonium
ion
and this is on the pica second time
scale shown in four frames
the ammonium ion is ejected from the
nanodroplet leaving behind a tail of
water and methanol
this tail breaks up and eventually the
ammonium ion
is released with a small cluster of
water and methanol
next slide tandem mass spectrometry
overview
the most frequently used mass spec
technologies include the triple
quadrupole quadruple time of flight
and the orbee trap these technologies
have three segments the first two
segments
these three systems share in common
they're a quadrupole
and a collision cell or fragmentation
cell
to select the precursor ion the first
quadrupole and then to fragment that
precursor
in the third segment they differ the
triple quadrupole has
a third quadrupole leading to the
detector the time of flight system
has a pulsar that collects bunches of
ions and injects those ions into a
flight tube
where they travel about a meter to a
detector the orbi trap system
has a trap it's called a c trap to
collect a bunch of ions
that are then injected into the orbee
which comprises a barrel
and spindle configuration the ions orbit
the spindle and the
image charge on the barrel is fourier
transform to generate
a spectrum in terms of operation
in scan mode the triple quadrupole is
inherently slower
and insensitive compared to the high
resolution systems the top and the
orbeez that are both fast and sensitive
in a typical acquisition the triple
quadruple system
uses selected reaction monitoring in the
first
quad the precursor ion is selected it is
fragmented
in the collision cell the second
quadrupole and then
one of those fragments is selected and
analyzed and detected by the third
quadrupole
so this is over a narrow mass range and
this is targeted
analysis you need to know the fragment
in the high resolution
systems a precursor ion is extracted
and then fragmented in the collision
cell all of those fragments
are then recorded in an extracted ion
chromatogram so this is
untargeted analysis at high resolution
to identify all of
the fragments in one scan
front-end separation techniques here
we're looking at high-performance
liquid chromatography hplc and solid
phase extraction
hplc operates with solvent pumps and
solvents
where the sample is loaded and mixed and
then pumped
across a separation column adsorbent
beads in the column
separate the analyte from the other
components of the sample matrix
the analyte is eluded with the solvent
and then directed to an electrospray
ionization source
over to your choice of mass spectrometer
in solid phase extraction there's a
disposable
cartridge this is the catch and release
system
so the sample is injected on the
cartridge the analyte
absorbs to the beads to the components
of the cartridge
the rest of the sample is washed away
then the analyte is eluded
in an organic solvent and then injected
it once again
onto the electrospray ionization source
for detection
fundamentally there is a separation
bottleneck the techniques we have for
separation include
gas chromatography liquid chromatography
solid phase extraction
and microfluidics um we have
analysis times from minutes to hours in
the case of gc
and lc and seconds to minutes for solid
phase extraction and microfluidics
the advantages of gc and lc these are
gold standard technologies been around
for decades
our high peak capacity high
reproducibility for gc
wide analyte coverage and high heat
capacity for lc disadvantages are
that gc is limited to volatile compounds
and the high temperature of the
ionization can cause analyte
fragmentation liquid chromatography has
inherently low throughput and the longer
the separation times
the better the results in solid phase
extraction
separation is faster it's ideal for
desalting and electroclass extraction
as however low peak capacity that's
similar
to direct infusion microfluidics
operates fast as therefore high
throughput
an inherently small sample volume and is
automatable
associated with a small sample volume is
lower sensitivity so cuts both ways
lower sensitivity for abundant samples
chromatography is inherently challenging
here we're looking at the progression
in the lower half of this slide over
three decades
the difference between these three
chromatograms they're identical
difference
is column size of the beads
so in the 80s over an eight minute
extraction
the separation rather the bead size is
five
microns reducing it by three and a half
microns in the 90s
yields three minutes in the 2000s we're
down to 1.8 microns
and a 1.5 minute separation and we're
not too far away from that
in the present day
now we're moving on to microfluidic
sampling with the
mini sprayer ion source
this is a very simple standard t-fitting
configuration
looking at port b we have a
free-standing liquid junction
that's suitable for sampling from
marketplace the
fluid makeup fluid fed into that
junction
originates in port m and that third port
is port k where pneumatically assisted
electrical ionization occurs
there's gas fed in the opening that's
shown as l it's a very simple
configuration for sampling
and electrospraying
the capillary gap sample dates of 2013
and
is a configuration you're seeing in the
top left there's a fused
silica capillary that's positioned
adjacent to the spray capillary or mass
spectrometry inlet
and a fluid flow a buffer flow and the
fused silica capillary
is forming a liquid bridge to the spray
capillary an extraction tool uh
by inserting an extraction tool into
liquid bridge sample can be desorbed
and then transferred to the mass
spectrometer for ionization
top right you're seeing a configuration
that's suitable for automation
and it is noted that as the gap volume
decreases
in the lower right sensitivity stability
and the limit of detection improve
acoustic ejection mass spectrometry here
we're looking at a cartoon of the system
that begins with acoustic droplet
ejection we have a two and a half
milliliter droplet injected into a
capture
region in the capture region we have a
vortex
the vortex is formed by carrier solvent
flowing from a carrier solvent pump in a
sheath flow it's a coaxial flow
down to the capture region to be
aspirated by a capillary
the capillary is connected to
electrospray ionization source
and there's simply a nebulizing
aspirator driving the flow it's a
balanced flow between the solvent pump
and the nebulizing aspiration
sample is diluted the droplets mix in
the vortex and are diluted and then
ionized
by standard esi in the top right we have
peaks generated by the system at two
samples per second at two hertz
when the carrier solvent is acetyl
natural a low viscosity solvent
the set of peaks is quite consistent as
you can see in the next panel down
that's about 2.5 two and a half percent
cv
we have a droplet ladder next from 10
droplets down to one droplet with
blanks injected in between each peak
as evidence of no carrier observed
a standard curve is the last graph on
the right in the lower right
and that is for propanol from 10
nanomolar
to 10 micromolar
acoustic droplet injection is versatile
in its ability to handle a wide range of
fluid classes as you can see
here in the top left we have a plot of
surface tension versus viscosity
looking at dmso our bread and butter
dating back to the early days
this is the standard compound storage
compound management
solution we have buffer we expanded from
dmso to aqueous solutions including
buffer
surfactant glycerol and our widest
calibration is
crystallography cp all of this operates
in microplates ranging from 96 well
through 384
all the way to 50 15 36 well geometries
the the cartoon on the right illustrates
the process of acoustic droplet ejection
we begin an acquiescent meniscus a mound
forms a droplet is ejected from the tip
of the mound
and travels upward to the destination
about one meter per second
the mound recedes and we end up once
again with a quiescent meniscus
and the droplet has attached is
uh stuck to the destination by surface
tension it does not
fall down all of this can be done at
high rep rate
uh 500 hertz and with high
volume accuracy and precision across
glycerol dmso fetal calf serum
tritonex 100 surfactant with cv's sub
three percent
here is the aems timeline we're
beginning with the capillary gap sampler
the micro sprayer
is actually off scale it's down in the
year 2000
the kepler gap sample sampler was
published by renato zinobi
in 2013 he's at eth zurich
in mid-2015 vilmaz curtis and gary van
berkel reported the open port probe
sampling interface this operated an
upright configuration
uh in an overflow mode so the kerryson
was overflowing the port
was primarily used for sampling solid
surfaces
or loading fluid samples with a pipette
tip
manually this work inspired a group at
science and lab site including don
arnold sammy delwani chenglu and myself
to
demonstrate a proof of concept that
integrates the open port probe
with acoustic droplet ejection
in november 2015 in redwood city this
was set up
on a triple quad mass spectrometer the
acoustic
transducer and the micro plate
source well were actually aligned
actually aligned to the
open port probe vortex such that droplet
ejection
is directed right to the core of the
vortex
this successful proof of concept led one
year later to a demonstration at psych's
headquarters in framingham massachusetts
where among other things we highlighted
a concordance between echo ms and lcms
for human liver metabolic stability
half-life comparison over a range of
compounds
leadership at science was convinced to
proceed and in mid-2017
we installed a breadboard system at
pfizer in groton connecticut
working with cuisine you can also see
tom covey in that photo
the data collected on that breadboard
system was presented at the podium
at asms 2018 by huizeng
in january 2019 lab site was acquired
by beckmann culture life sciences and
opco
of danaher corporation the following
asms
in 2019 psyx pre-announced
the commercial release of the echo ms
and we eagerly anticipate
the official commercial release uh any
week now
mid-2020
here's what the breadboard system looks
like these are installed at merck and
plyser
you're looking at a 3d four poly for a
source plate mounted to an xy
stage you can see the open port
interface with two lines coming in one
for the carrier solvent
and one the capillary carrier the mix of
solvent
and sample for electrospray ionization
that's in the top
panel in the lower left we have the
acoustic transducer in a black housing
there's coupling fluid to connect the
transducer to
the bottom of the source plate for a
continuous fluid path
in the lower right we have the opi
housing and you can see
the gap between the housing and the
capillary that's where the sheath
carrier solvent flow occurs and then you
can see the
inner diameter of the capillary where
the vortex forms due to capillary
aspiration
in operation there's a video
to be shown here we're going to
highlight the
coverage the performance of this system
as conventional electrospray ionization
with wide and light coverage
this is an intact antibody standard at
150 kilodaltons
we're looking at two different
concentrations 10x difference limit of
detection is less than one
femtomole loading in the lower right
we have a choline transporter assay
where once again
we're demonstrating concordance with
lcms
over a range of inhibitor and stimulator
compounds with good agreement
[Music]
on the top left is a set of
plasma samples ranging from protein
precipitated
through neat plasma we're looking at
triplicate sets of peaks the analyte is
verapamil and what you notice is as we
go from protein precipitated
through 50 50 plasma water some with
formic acid all the way to neat plasma
we get a consistent set of peaks
we see slightly lower peaks or neat
plasma
due to some iron suppression but we have
sufficient signal
nevertheless to generate a standard
curve in all four cases
in the top right we have two peptides at
three different concentrations
looking at the effect of surfactant a
potent ion suppressor
so in the lower rate you can see with
and without
0.01 percent between 20 no ion
suppression
is observed
the next example is a demonstration of
real-time kinetics monitoring
we're looking at a sip 2d6 enzymatic
reaction
showing substrate dxm converted to
metabolite dxo that's dextromethorphan
over a 30 minute time course you can see
the intensity of
dxm decline as the product dxo
increases at each time point we have a
measurement
of six concentrations in duplicate we
get a linear response
the peak area over time at each
concentration
increases linearly with a good linear
fit good r squared
and we can analyze that with a
michaelis-menten
fit to the formation rate for metabolism
of dxm
to dxo by sip2d6 in human liver
microsomes
yielding a km 3.79 in agreement with
reported values
now we want to address fluorescent probe
artifacts
here we have an acyl transferase
activity assay
looking at glycerol 3-phosphate
in combination with a cofactor acyl coa
and the acyl transferase enzyme
converting to
phosphatic acid you want to look at
panel c and f initially so here we're
going
uh looking at the the relevance the
importance of the presence of both
acyl transferees and cofactor product is
only produced
when we have both the enzyme and the
cofactor
present moving to panel e we're sweeping
from low to high
the concentration of the cofactor acyl
coa and you can see there is a peak
going to the lower panel g looking at
the one micromolar
point you can see discrepancy in the
dotted line which is the ecoms data
and the fluorescent data the co-a
co-a-green
assay this is because there is a
15-minute
incubation required as part of the
protocol to
couple as part of the reagent coupling
reaction other fluorescent acid during
that 15-minute incubation
some product forms the phosphatic acid
forms as a result
the fluorescent plate reader reports a
false formation rate
and cannot fluorescence assays therefore
cannot determine true enzyme
enzyme kinetics due to confounding
kinetics of the reagent
coupling reaction
now we have high throughput
experimentation this is a chemical
reaction pathway screening or a simple
reaction looking at a range of different
96 conditions to produce this product
this is run via lcms and echo ms
using high resolution mass spectrometry
lcms operates at 10 microliters per
sample injection three minutes
per sample analysis the echoms
on the other hand requires only five
nanoliters per sample injection
and three seconds per sample for
analysis
as a result 96 wells in lcms take a
total of five
hours the same data quality can be
achieved
in just five minutes with the echo ms
system that's 60 times faster at 1 000
x lower sample volume
now we have a recent example this is a
collaboration with merck
the selective in well extraction using a
two-phase pentanol water mixture
we developed a custom calibration to
enable direct ejection of droplets
from the upper pentanol phase there is a
legacy
lcmf method or employed by the two-phase
extraction employed as a two-phase
extraction
to selectively enrich for lipid analyte
in the upper tensional layer and
sequester the salts
in the lower aqueous phase that you're
seeing in cartoon of what that well
looks like in the lower left and in the
lower
right we have the echoes generated from
each interface
there's four echoes there's the bottom
of bottom top and bottom
the liquid liquid interface and the
pentanal
air meniscus reflections
dgat 2 is diacyl glycerol acyl
transferase
1 or 2. it catalyzes the rate limiting
step
in triglyceride synthesis this is a
challenging target it's a membrane
enzyme that's screened by lcms
our colleagues and merck have previously
reported on the comparison
of fluorescent and lcms assays for the
identification
of the dgat2 inhibitors looking at the
center panel
in the middle you're seeing the
fluorescent cpm assay
there is a curve that is identified as
the upright triangles sf9 mock
that's the background level of the
fluorescent assay
the signal is the top curve that's the
active dgat2 membrane
there's an issue with signal to
background in the fluorescent assay
it's a ratio of three in comparison the
lcm messes on the right has much lower
background
signal to background is eight-fold
we established concordance for ecoms
to recapitulate the ic-50s determined by
lcms for 40 compounds
and of 2. ec50 correlation
yielded a slope of 0.86 and r squared of
0.82
the minimum significant ratio was less
than 2
so we have good concordance
finally a mini screen was run six
thousand four cop 400 compounds were run
by both the cpm
fluorescent assay and echo ms
surprisingly
it was revealed that echo rescued a
large
group of actives they're shown in the
green box that were
cpm false negatives there could be some
real
important hits potentially clinically
relevant compounds in this group
in conclusion aems is transformative
the open port interface addresses the
front end
separation bottleneck direct dilution of
sorry direct injection and dilution in a
continuous
flow of carry solvent eliminates the
need for separation
no lc is required there's a tolerance
for complex matrices
we are free of carry over acoustic
droplet ejection
provides high precision touchless
nanoliter droplet transfer allows for
assay miniaturization conserves original
sample
and operates with a wide range of
microplates
there is no compromise in data quality
and we offer up to 50 times
faster sample analysis
the details are listed here on the right
it's important to acknowledge the
contributions of the extensive team
at beckmann psyx merck and pfizer
whose diligence and dedication led to
the success of this project
thank you very much